melissa is in st. Paul hi Melissa how
are you hi I'm good this is such a
pleasure so thank you for taking my call
thank you how can I help okay so my
husband has a small business he's a
carpenter we have made a mistake by not
paying taxes year-round so now it's tax
time we owe the IRS 12 grand my question
is what is the best way about paying
back this money I am an FPU I'm a baby
step number 2 but I am I assume I should
pay taxes before everything correct work
um do I put ledger house what is your
household income pre-tax is about 70
grand okay and so he is running his own
business yeah and have you now set up a
separate checking account for his
business and any money that goes into
that account any money he makes in the
business goes into that account and only
business expenses come out of that
account and any money you pull out of
that account to bring home called profit
you set aside 1/4 of it in a separate
savings account starting today so that
your withholding or your holded
withholding on yourself so that this
doesn't happen again okay that's first
and foremost you have to stop the leak
first and foremost awfully we need to
stop it yes yes your 1/4 of his income a
quarter of whatever he takes out of the
business and brings home is your profit
okay yeah and a quarter of your profit
and you set that aside for taxes and
you're supposed to pay quarterly
estimates on a small business like this
so you're supposed to pay in once a
quarter and it's a one-page sheet it's
not real difficult to fill out and one
of our endorsed local providers or
whoever does your taxes can help you do
that okay yeah we need to do it we I yes
we need to we've been saying this for
years yep and it goes come back to bite
you and it has an effect
okay so you have any money saved we do
we have we have about 2500 I have mapped
out the next three months and I think if
we don't take out any money which I
understand we have to but I have it set
up where if we didn't take out any money
and we put all our money into the Texas
at Waco we could have it paid off by the
end of May what do you might make out
where you mean take out any money what
all of our income like so our monthly
expenses is for grant but we're bringing
in about seven grand a month right now
but that's not taxed so with that we
could I was wondering if I pay it back
really really quick and then start
paying forward once that would be okay
but you should be able to do that by um
don't you do just as fast as you can
okay and no matter what happens
regardless of if you don't pay the taxes
on time you file on time for sure yeah
we've-- filing an extension does not
give you an extension on payment yeah
okay so go ahead and file by April 15th
and you're going to be late on some of
your taxes so you're going to have a
little bit of penalty on the portion
that you're late of course we want to
pile up as much as we can possibly pile
up by April 15th to avoid penalty on it
okay
oh well last year we had until 2
September to handle well you didn't
no you didn't you got penalized on but
there was a penalty okay okay you get
penalized yeah you do not have the
option to delay payment with an
extension you have the option to extend
your filing but there's no reason to
extend the filing you've got the
paperwork yes we have the paperwork go
ahead and file it and just don't pay on
time and then they're still going to hit
you with the penalty on the portion you
don't pay by April 15th but you got
twenty five hundred which has got us
down to ninety five hundred today yeah
and this is you know you still got a
month and a half no you don't yeah you
know you got a month but um anyway yeah
you're going to have to scrape it claw
how much can you put together more by
the
15th of April do you think gosh maybe
another grand ok cool that's great
because 8500 then and you're going to
clean that up by down in May you said
yeah you know I actually I think I could
get it to about 5 grand by April good
every dime you get them is going to keep
you from being penalized on it okay so
you're saying yeah even paying them as
much as I because I was wondering if we
should just make the payment once we
have it all no no no no because you're
being taxed you're being penalized on
whatever you don't pay by April 15
I didn't know that okay I don't know why
we didn't do that like well we didn't
know that so okay okay
pay as much as we I might be able to I
think we could have half by April good
and then the other half already quick
and it's out of your way and then fix
this so it never happens again by
starting to behold on yourself okay so
would you recommend an envelope for that
or for the monthly from now on or just
between now and then for monthly for now
on once this called grand no I would
just say heard open a little separate
account separate savings account and
when you pull money out of his business
checking account like if you pull $1,000
out right one check to 750 to come home
one check for 250 for taxes and you put
it in savings okay and you pull 2,000
out you write a check for 500 into
savings 1,500 comes home that's 1/4 and
3/4 okay and it just has to be that way
and I hope it will get easier and you
you have to it's not your money it's
already gone you're right it's not my
money I it's gonna it the problem is
it's gonna continually smack you guys in
the back and they had the rest of your
life to you fixes I know and it's gotten
worse and worse every year because you
made more money exactly
the downside is he makes more money than
if the hole is bigger because we're not
addressing it and it's never a surprise
we know it's coming and so you live with
this kind of bad taste in the back of
your mouth like you did something stupid
and we did do something stupid well
that's my other taste yeah but you could
fix it you know exactly what to do now
and then see your tax person and
with that savings account you can file
your quarterly estimates because now if
you don't file quarterly estimates you
get penalized for this you talk to her
for this year yeah exactly and if she
doesn't didn't explaining that to you
you may need a different tax person
because that that's what you're getting
hammered on here so hey good question
I'm glad you're getting on top of this
Melissa it's a man that stuff used to
drive me crazy when I first started in
business it just at the IRS man it puts
more people out of business than
anything else does because it's not the
IRS doing it I mean I'm not a fan of the
IRS but it's us not taking care of
business and setting our taxes aside
it's one of the biggest things that
knocks a beginner business out just
knocks them out cold
so hey thank you for the call and I'm
glad you're straightening it up this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you